there are new questions about the
mysterious death of a decorated Marine
Colonel Colonel Michael Stallman was
discovered with a bullet wound in his
head in his accommodation in Iraq nearly
11 years ago
military officials declared it a suicide
but his wife is determined to prove he
was murdered Peter Vansant investigates
for this week's 48 hours in July 2008
colonel michael Stallman was about to
come home from iraq for R&R with his
family when the military lawyer and
former flight officer was found in his
quarters with a gunshot wound to the
head he died about two months later
authorities called it a suicide but
Stallman's wife Kim and daughter Makenna
say the man they loved would never have
killed himself I don't ever recall him
being upset or sad someone shot him are
you certain of that I have no doubt Kim
says her husband was a righty
but his wound was on the left side and
his job helping rebuild Iraq's legal
system could easily have made him
enemies I just feel like it was somebody
might new at the heart of the mystery an
email that was sent just hours before
the gun shot Kim
sorry about what you were about to find
out I love you and always will you and
the girls are the best thing that ever
happened to me love Mike but was it
really a suicide note
the evidence shows there's no way he
could have done what they said he did
you're not in denial no Kim started
pushing the investigating agency NCIS
for more information and she soon
enlisted some important allies Silla
McCain and author and advocate for
bereaved military families I just do not
believe that he pulled that trigger and
Michael Maloney a forensic investigator
who had once worked for NCIS
this is a homicide there was someone
else in that room he'd left before the
Stallman incident
but NCIS did hire blood-stained expert
mark Reynolds I see no evidence of
homicide in the materials provided to me
whatsoever
he says Michael Maloney is guessing pure
speculation or just plain wrong
there's no evidence to support anything
other than a suicide two experts two and
very different to use if this was a
suicide I would have to accept it but
it's hard when you know that that's not
what it was the truth needs to come out
either good morning if that last email
to his family was not a suicide note
what might it have been well it was it a
reference to you're about to find my
body that you're going to learn that I
had a relationship with another woman
that I'm about to be deployed
it's just uncertain and Kim the widow
had this sent to a linguist who
concluded it was not a suicide note and
when you're in a war zone
people speak cryptically and use strange
phrases sometimes to try to communicate
so that's still unsettled they'll debate
after ten years Peter thank you very
much he's 48 hours report widow's war
airs tomorrow night at 10:00 9:00
central right here on CBS